a twenty-year-old Southern California
man is charged with murder in the
stabbing death of a former high school
classmate 19-year old Ivy League student
blaze Bernstein was reportedly stabbed
more than 20 times his body was found in
a park earlier this month one week after
he disappeared
Mireya Villarreal is at Borrego Park in
Lake Forest California where a good
morning well good morning the memorial
behind me and blaze Bernstein's honor
has continued to grow over the last few
days with candles flowers and special
messages some from people who didn't
even know him Bernstein had been home on
break from the University of
Pennsylvania visiting his parents I did
sit down with him yesterday they said
that this death has been extremely
difficult for them in every way
imaginable when we think of a future
without blaze look that's crushing for
us Jeanne and Gideon Bernstein are
looking for justice as legal proceedings
began Wednesday against the man accused
of killing their son the court will call
the matter of people vs. Samuel Lincoln
Woodward prosecutors say Samuel Woodward
picked up Blaise Bernstein at his
parents home back on January 2nd after
the two communicated on snapchat
Bernstein's parents reported him missing
the next day and one week later his body
was found in a shallow grave in this
park
investigators say Woodward had scratches
and dirt on his hands while under
surveillance he returned to the crime
scene and also cleaned his vehicle it
generally means that they're trying to
that that person is trying to destroy
evidence
he was arrested Friday police say no
weapons had been found and they are
still trying to determine the motive in
this case but according to an affidavit
attained by the Orange County Register
Woodward told investigators he became
angry after Bernstein who was gay kissed
him the night he disappeared
could there be a consideration for a
hate crime that's certainly an open
question and that's and we are in fact
looking for evidence that that might
support that Bernstein was studying
psychology and worked on a campus
culinary magazine his friends and family
gathered at a memorial service earlier
this week
now this bright young soul with this
world
at his fingertips and then all of a
sudden their God he was learning to love
himself and I think he was there it just
tears me up he was ready he was ready to
just be himself and be proud the
suspects attorney says the Woodward's
family is actually in shock as well
they're trying to figure out how an
Eagle Scout is now accused of murder
Samuel Woodward is being held in the
jail without bond he did not enter a
plea yesterday he's expected to be back
in court early next month in front of a
judge on a formal arraignment john maria
thanks